of the students Maxwell glamini has been
charged with terrorism and Sedition he
says for calling for democratic reform
in Africa's last absolute monarchy is
swatini formerly Swaziland and I stayed
you know 14 months without pay in prison
and then I subsequently could be you
know after an appeal and then
International campaign for my release
is a member of an opposition group The
People's United Democratic movement and
is due to return to this court he says
he's been beaten tortured and spent up
to four years in police custody what do
you make of the charges
you know that the government could
actually arrest a young activists you
know for criticizing government and
calling for a more democratic
and the Constitutional party democracy
and the charge the Motorola you know
without even involving any of all
Kingdom Swati III is ruled in swatini
for more than 35 years
before that his father was Monarch
following the Kingdom's independence
from the United Kingdom opposition
parties have accused the government of
using excessive force in its response to
demonstrations calling for change in
2021 and 2022 according to Human Rights
Watch at least 80 people were killed and
more than one thousand arrested in a
matter of months it says along with a
lack of democratic reforms human rights
and swatini are deteriorating the
government says it was responding to
criminal Acts including the Looting of
businesses anyone in this country can
express himself through a mass protest
through delivering petitions wherever
they choose and whenever they choose to
do so however you would know that
demonstrations should be guided and
regulated at least two members of
parliament who called for democracy were
arrested in 2021 and remain in custody
they too have been charged with
terrorism
it's a very very difficult situation for
activists who are constantly being
arrested the world will know of tulani
masego renowned human rights lawyer and
activist for for political reforms in
the country so I've learned who was
killed actually this year January and to
this day the state has not provided any
report on any investigation and
whatsoever so it's a very difficult
situation for human rights political
parties have been banned since the 1970s
but the government says there are no
laws enforcing that
still many opposed to eswatini's
political system and its monarchy have
fled to neighboring South Africa where
they say they will continue their
fighting
foreign
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera